si le secteur de l'immobilier s'effondre
en chine et ce secteur il faut toujours
le rappeler représente pratiquement 30%
presqu'un tiers du pib de la chine est
bien la crise sera profonde parce que ça
touche aussi une partie de l'industrie
qui alimente ce secteur est par ailleurs
ces crises ne fera pas que toucher la
chine
[Musique]
place maintenant notre chronique
économique rendez vous incontournable du
jeudi la question qu'on se pose ce soir
et si la prochaine crise financière
venait de chine déjà épicentre
historique du coc vide la deuxième
économie mondiale doit maintenant gérer
la déconfiture de son secteur immobilier
avec la chute des verts rendre ce
promoteur en défaut de paiement qui
croule sous une montagne de dettes après
avoir vu beaucoup trop grand alors pékin
est il en mesure de limiter la casse
l'immobilier chinois peut-il entraîner
une nouvelle crise comparable à celle
des subprimes on en parle tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir seller
dit aux échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec nous
même à distance alors que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui dans l'immobilier en chine
eh bien c'est fini on est probablement
en présence des prémices d'une crise
financière majeure l'immobilier chinois
a donné naissance à des sociétés qui
sont devenus de véritables gérant fait
parler des verts grande et bien sûr mais
il ya aussi d'autres comme fantasia ou
cynique ces sociétés sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement d'été elles sont confrontées
à la stabilisation voire à la baisse des
prix tant de la demande que de leur
secteur d'activité la situation s'est
donc dégradé depuis ces derniers mois et
il faut bien dire que les mesures qui
ont été prises par le gouvernement
chinois ont fait plus qu aggraver cette
situation
planté le décor qu'est-ce que et d'art
grande alors évacué a été créée en 1996
tout d'abord dans l'immobilier est la
vraie véritablement décoller à partir
des années 2000 quand le gouvernement
chinois a massivement soutenu le secteur
du logement le résultat était un
développement tout à fait astronomiques
la valeur de la société a été multiplié
par 8 de 2009 à 2010 est autrement dit
un taux de croissance de 30% par an
evergrande et a poursuivi une expansion
très agressive y compris dans des
entreprises qui sont très éloignées de
son secteur d'origine par exemple des
entreprises de véhicules électriques les
parcs à thèmes et bien d'autres secteurs
ainsi evergrande et a dépensé plus de 7
milliards de dollars entre 2019 et 2021
rien que dans le développement des
véhicules électriques alors ces
investissements comprennent aussi par
exemple le développement de l'eau chaude
flower island une un projet de
construction d'îles artificielles dans
la mer de chine et vers granby est donc
devenu aujourd'hui un conglomérat géant
même à l'échelle chinoise alors pourquoi
les problèmes financiers
actuel avec ce que vous nous décrivez
alors l'endettement des verts grande et
stéphanie et des normes sont passives
autrement dit l'argent qu'elle doit aux
banques aux fonds d'investissement aux
autres sociétés immobilières et à des
particuliers dans le cadre d'une
politique de préachat des logements et
bien cet endettement atteint
actuellement 310 milliards de dollars
grosso modo 275 milliards d'euros
autrement dit 12% du pib de la france
ces empreintes avait été gagé sur le
portefeuille immobilier de l'entreprise
or depuis un an comme je les dis les
prix de l'immobilier ont cessé
d'augmenter certains ont même commencé à
baisser et donc la valeur immobilière du
capital qui sert de garantie à ses
empreintes se contracte les
investisseurs qui avaient prêté à river
grande et s'inquiète de plus il ya
maintenant des rumeurs de fraudes qui
circulent de manière insistante depuis
le mois d'octobre 2000 21 h ces
pratiques il faut le dire ne se limite
pas à evere grandes elles sont courantes
dans plusieurs grandes sociétés
immobilières chinoises et on peut donc
penser que et 20 grandes pourrait être
un petit peu la face émergée la partie
émergée de l'iceberg financiers en chine
alors jacques le gouvernement chinois
est ce qu il a pris la conscience quand
même du problème que vous nous décrivez
oui naturellement naturellement et dans
un effort pour freiner l'endettement
excessif du secteur immobilier le
gouvernement chinois a adopté une
stratégie dite des trois lignes rouges
en 2020 pour justement limiter les
volumes dans près alors ça veut dire que
les différentes sociétés doivent
respecter trois ratios un ratio entre
leurs niveaux de dette et les liquidités
immédiates qu'elles ont un ratio entre
les dettes et les fonds propres en
général un autre ratio entre les dettes
et les actifs ces réglementations il
faut bien lire ont fortement impacté
evergrande --la société a annoncé en
mars 2021 qu'elle cherchait à réduire
son endettement de 23 milliards de
dollars 23 milliards de dollars par
rapport à 310 milliards de dollars on
voit c'est pas énorme malgré tout comme
réduction mais au moins il faut aussi
rappeler qu'evergrande était toujours en
expansion l'année dernière elle avait
lancé une pas moins de 60 trois projets
dans le cours de 2021 alors d'autres
réglementations été prise que ce soit
par le gouvernement central ou par les
gouvernements locaux le résultat c'est
que en octobre 2021 quatorze des trente
plus grandes sociétés immobilières
chinoises se trouvait en infraction avec
au moins une des règles alors l'une
était en infraction avec les trois
règnes que j'ai cités evergrande et et
greenland holding en avait enfreint deux
et les 11 autres sociétés avaient
enfreint au moins une de ces
réglementations et on se demande
évidemment que peut faire pétain tv la
marge de manoeuvre
oui effectivement alors en plus il ya le
problème des risques que vous comprenez
bien le risque il est tout d'abord
direct un certain nombre de banques de
fonds d'investissement américains ou
européens on prêtait déjà de l'argent
aille vers gorgue et subirait évidemment
les conséquences d'une faillite de cette
société cependant le risque est aussi
peut-être même surtout un risque
indirect déjà des sociétés de taille
moyenne comme fantasia ou chimiques sont
en défaut de paiement mais avec
l'hypothétique faillite d'evergrande il
faudrait s'attendre à ce que de
nombreuses sociétés soit entraîné avec
elle car si le secteur de l'immobilier
s'effondre en chine et ce secteur il
faut toujours le rappeler représente
pratiquement 30% presqu'un tiers du pib
de la chine est bien la crise sera
profonde parce que ça touche aussi une
partie de l'industrie qui alimente ce
secteur est par ailleurs ces crises ne
fera pas que toucher la chine une forte
récession de l'économie chinoise
contaminera immédiatement les économies
occidentales celle des effectifs a su
mais aussi celle de l'allemagne qui
exporte beaucoup par rapport à la chine
merci jacques sapir